oh
interesting observation turbo queer also
love the name
ah
yeah my uh my growth stagnated again on
the channel it does that intermittently
semi-regularly actually
hmm
oh well
laughs
hope everyone's doing well
really you're gonna you're gonna claim
that this is not water
what you want
all done with Steven Universe really
enjoyed it okay Jason did that include a
future
a movie the movie and Future
hey there 255 A.D hello adrenaline hello
Gozer Ms Wicked Wolf bookworm
track which are you lovely lovely folks
homebody
I'm probably gonna miss some
so uh yeah movie and future too ah good
is it weird that my single favorite
thing out of the whole run of the show
might just be peridot's bit at the end
of the theme song for future just
standing up and going Steven Universe
future
I don't know it's my favorite bit I
don't know what to tell you
watch the teaser for Pixar's new movie
Elio earlier today they have a teaser
for their new movie their current one's
not even out yet they're teasing the
next well I guess they are uh I guess
they're giving up on Elemental right off
the bat if they feel like oh geez stop
promoting the one that's coming out
quick quick show them the next thing we
have
that didn't bode well
my family's planning on having a seafood
boil at the end of the month lovely not
a big fan of seafood but I hope you have
a lot of fun
uh
uh I appreciate the thought with that a
Bob I
I don't like to say that I'm a better
person than anybody but I certainly do
my best to try and not
been to a lot of the traps that
I think a lot of the anti-woke creators
fall into I do call them traps because
they're out there for anybody you know
just
finding a thing that gets you attention
and doing it as hard as possible
because I've gone on this tangent
elsewhere but long story short
while there is a percentage of these
people who very sincerely believe the
things they say there are
uh a very significant percentage of them
who I either strongly suspect or in some
cases have on good authority they don't
really believe what they say but it's
what they've turned into their living so
they continue to say it
now that makes them no less damaging but
that is a Content Creator's trap not
necessarily to be radicalized but to let
what make what what grows your channel
become the only thing that drives it
because if you focus on that and forget
everything else you're going to very
quickly find yourself making things that
you don't believe and you don't support
but you do anyway because it pays your
bills
so
wait until you get to Mayhem the theme
song really sticks in your head I need
to try and find the time for that I need
to try and find the time for ah lots of
things
my old man is fantastic at cooking Cajun
and Creole food ooh authentic I love it
grifter's gonna grift yeah pretty much
anti-wokism is sad imagine living your
life like I am against people being
aware yeah it
however they choose to Rebrand it when
you whenever you drill down on
anti-woke or anti-sjw or anti-political
correctness and you drill down to what
actually bothers them if you can get
them to admit what they actually have a
problem with
it's always very telling
it's basically the equivalent of when
somebody goes well I I believe in states
rights and you then press them on okay
states rights to do what
the right to do what
they'll either back off or they'll uh
they'll let slip what they actually care
about
what is the worst aspect about your
favorite doctor
I
I'll just go Petty because it's what
came to my mind I love Peter Capaldi but
he has that that dotted jumper it looks
like it's supposed to be a star field or
something I hate it it's hideous shows
up in like two episodes it's really ugly
I really hate it
I think they just want control some of
them do but the thing to remember turbo
queer is that applies to those actually
in seats of political power
a lot of the people on the content
creation side they don't have actual
power they don't have actual control
they do it for money
and
whether or not they think they have
control because again you'll get a
handful of True Believers who actually
believe the they say but like
there is a difference in mentality
between doing it for tangible control of
other people and doing it for money the
outcome is still the same like again
I will equate all these people together
and say you're all equal equally
terrible but like it is I think helpful
to understand the difference in
reasoning if only to better understand
why they do what they do or why they say
what they say because if you don't
understand what drives different people
to ultimately be saying and doing the
same thing then you're not going to
understand their
uh their tactics and their approaches
and they're going to seem contradictory
this is a conversation I've had with
multiple people across my life often um
like with friends or relatives who
aren't nearly as online as this job kind
of requires me to be but
um you know people going like well they
say this but then they also say this or
they say this and they do this and it
doesn't make sense and I have to go like
it does because the ones who say this
thing
truly believe it and the ones who say
this thing are in it for the money
so
you know understanding the different
motivations at the very least helps you
not bang your head against the wall
trying to try to make sense of the
contradictions
a while ago Matt Walsh was doing a
screed about how the colonization of the
Americas was good actually he still had
to work some anti-trans stuff into it of
course he did like that's literally the
only reason anyone pays attention to him
so of course he did
I thought oh you really can't talk about
not talk about the subject for like two
seconds no we really can't
plus you know
the uh the destruction of millions of
indigenous people in their displacement
and the Erasure of their culture was
good actually ah off
I try not to swear on here but but very
sincerely speaking as someone who had
multiple relatives come over on the
Mayflower whose literal ancestors my
ancestors people I can name
literally started this country
em
they're all terrible I have every right
to say it that's my people
that's not to say other people don't
have a right to say it they do everybody
say it all together now
the pilgrims there we go nicely
done well harmonized good good work
everybody I'm proud of I'm proud of what
we've done here today
um
I saw someone I knew uh who before the
pandemic was a typical liberal Canadian
turning into Trump pumping oh God that's
just an unpleasant pairing of words tin
foil hat anti-vaxx anti-world person
it's unreal
the pandemic
the pandemic did a lot of interesting
things to people I mean largely the
pandemic
forced a lot of people to spend a lot of
time inside their own heads
and that's why there's a hell like
there's a reason why like when it's
trending on say Twitter or Instagram and
it's like trans people being like
picture from yourself three years ago
and now it's a reason why right now it's
three years ago because that was
pre-pandemic so you know a lot of people
took inward Journeys and you know
discovered themselves to be
queer discovered themselves to be trans
discovered themselves to be a
witch but a bunch of other people got
lost in their own heads and spiraled
and
you know the
the thing is that there there probably
was some seed of that before but you
know when you're trapped inside
and the main person that you're
conversing with is yourself
odds are you're gonna become more
yourself for good or ill
John vinyls thank you very much for the
Super Chat and this is your reminder
Super Chat I does guarantee that I will
read your comment I try and keep up with
the chat but I don't promise anything
Super Chat does guarantee it plus you
get a heart from me hmm
watched movie Bob's breakdown of what
happened to the dceu and I kept
wondering how the whole thing could have
gone well and bloomed into something
truly great I haven't seen it I haven't
watched movie Bob stuff for a couple
years
to
two years or so
I'm I don't know he uh honestly
I think the last thing I watched from
him was the last time he did really that
good and
you know because I'd really enjoyed
those and I really liked his
um
his his gems you know seriously I liked
his more positive stuff but it's he's
kind of tapered off that and I
understand a lot of it was a lot of work
I do get that but I I just was like I'm
right I'm ready to move on
um but in terms of that thought
I mean
the main thing that the dceu did was to
try to catch up to Marvel
and like honestly they were kind of in a
no-win situation because either
they were going to have to try and build
what Marvel did similar to the PACE that
Marvel did it and just always be behind
you know they'd be making uh they'd be
making Justice League around the time
that Marvel was releasing end game and
they just seemed behind the times or
they could do what they did which was to
try and speed the process and just
end up with a disaster because one they
tried to rush what was done with what
was done more organically over a Marvel
and in order to rush it they had to lay
down a bunch of plans that
couldn't really change without a train
wreck and then have
them the things start to hit wrong and
then try and change the things and not
have it be a train wreck and it was
so
it honestly I think the best thing DC
could have done
was um
was just not do the shared universe
like that was never gonna happen because
you know too many Executives were going
well Marvel's doing it and and they the
the money
we want money so like they were always
going to try and do it just like
everyone else even people without comic
book
um Universe has tried to do it
Dark Universe God anyways
but like just artistically what would
have been the best thing was would have
been just to
basically just start making stuff like
the Batman and honestly The Joker I
don't even like the Joker but
artistically it's a hell of a lot more
Justified and better just as a artistic
product that I don't even like but like
it's a hell of a lot more Justified to
exist than the than the first Suicide
Squad movie or bvs
it or the theatrical cut of Justice
League for that matter and I didn't even
mind that movie that much but like it's
trash it's absolute garbage
and
I think what would have been the best
thing artistically and I do underline
artistically because the business side
never would have let them do this would
have been to just let it continue to be
Standalone things
don't make it a shared universe just
work on making good individual
franchises but they wouldn't do that
so there we go
have I seen the Justice League War World
trailer nope
uh
have you watched don't worry darling if
so what do you think about it I have not
I doubt I will unless uh somebody wants
to pay me to see it it wasn't really
something that was pinging my radar much
anyway then the reactions to it came out
like oh well heck with it
um
what do you think your life would look
like if the pandemic can never happened
so
if I'm gonna take a completely selfish
look at my own life
the pandemic was good for me
and I don't mean like the pandemic was
good for the world it wasn't the
pandemic was an awful thing and the fact
that it happened and on the scale that
it did was atrocious and horrible and it
was a failure of so many systems and
leadership in government and failures of
humanity it was horrible
but
what my life would look like if the
pandemic had never happened
honestly
I don't know but it it would be shaky
because the fact that I'm able to do
this as my living
was made possible by
a rapid series of events firstly I was
laid off and I was laid off officially
because of the pandemic I've talked
before about what I think the real
reason they laid me off was but it
doesn't matter officially it was because
of the pandemic
and I I let people know hey I've lost my
job but if I can get more support on the
patreon
I can maybe do this for a living and
there was a boost in support but the
thing is that boost of support wow it it
got me where I am now that would not
have been enough on its own
I also needed to have unemployment and
the stimulus payments now like I haven't
gotten unemployment for two years and
the stimulus payments dried up months
ago so I'm sustaining now I'm steady now
but like to initially get my feet under
me I needed all of that
and if the pandemic had never happened I
was I was
extremely checked out of my job I was so
checked out that within another year
they probably would have been able to
fire me for uh failure to meet sales
goals and like performance issues
and if they and if you're fired for that
you don't get unemployment and even if I
got a boost from my supporters it might
not have been enough and the stimulus
checks wouldn't have happened and I
don't know where I would I would have
ended up I mean probably what would have
happened is maybe I would have gotten
a part-time job
and then tried to make working part-time
somewhere work while trying to build
this into what I was able to dedicate my
whole time to because I didn't have to
hold down even a part-time job
so again narrowing down to only my own
life talking only about me
because it's all about me talking only
about me the pandemic and how it
directly impacted my life led to some of
the best things that have happened to me
uh as an adult
and I feel a little bad saying that
because again I'm not saying the
pandemic was good it wasn't
isn't it's still like
keep your keep your vaccine up to date
seriously
John vinyls I think Bob has actually
said he's going to do a new really that
good episode in the near future and yes
it is some of his best stuff well if he
does maybe I'll check that out
um today I asked the culture subreddit
if I could have approval to see the
culture subreddit
during the
read the
Read It Strike because I missed I'm not
following that
I'm not following that uh 255 I need the
mobs just told me too bad which were my
feelings a bit
um
during the Reddit strike Peak I now it
completely over my head I feel like I'm
missing some context there
I still go see Justice League around the
time of end game why would that be a bad
thing
from the perspective I mean the thing is
Alyssa from the perspective of business
people they're behind and they're not
the market leader and if you're not the
market leader your investors want to
know why
and so being very clearly the follower
and being behind may not have been awful
for the
films
but that is why they didn't go with that
option
have you seen across the spider verse
yes yes I have my review will be up in
the break room on Thursday and on
Saturday
will be a video on this channel covering
uh some aspects that I wanted to devote
as their own video
oh
can you imagine if James Cameron did a
Doctor Who episode which famous
filmmaker would you want to do Doctor
Who none of them
I I don't
it just feels like such a gimmick I
don't see a lot of the appeal of getting
a big name director because like
how many of them are going to be able to
do something actually interesting within
the confines of a doctor who budget
I mean you know Spielberg Cameron uh
Nolan whoever else you care to name like
what are they even gonna make within the
restrictions of the time frame and the
budgetary limits and the resource limits
of an episode of Doctor freaking who
I don't think I I feel like what people
think it would be is never what the
reality could be so that's why my
general thought is like what why why why
why I mean like look if they ever if
if Peter Jackson and Edgar Wright ever
wanted to direct episodes of Doctor Who
I wouldn't say no they'd be too who
actually think might be able to do
something interesting because they both
have
um more of a low budget background
um and Edgar Wright in particular has a
TV background but
like overall I just don't
I don't get the appeal of those kinds of
pitches like other people get excited by
ideas like that I just don't
I don't know I don't get it and the
other thing to keep in mind is they
would just be directors
a lot of the unique flavor they bring to
their movies is because they're involved
at the scripting phase a lot of these
people aren't screenwriters themselves
but they do
um
they do get involved in crafting the
story that they want to direct with
whoever the screenwriter is and they
wouldn't be able to do that on Doctor
Who so again like I just don't
get
I just I just don't get why
I want to print a shirt that says lgbtq
lives matter but I want to avoid
excluding anyone if I say lgbtq plus
that will be okay well the first thing
to remember is
opinions are going to vary depending on
who you ask I think that for most people
either lgbtq Plus or lgbtqia plus as
long as you've got the Plus in there
we'll probably consider it to be fairly
all to be fairly inclusive some people
might still wish you went with a longer
one than you did
um I've seen it go as long as they'll be
lgbtqia PK is the longest I've seen it
and I'm kind of iffy about some of the
the latter ones that end up on there
when you go that long but I I think
getting the Plus in there will will do
you well
you took the card you were dealt and got
out winning good for you thank you Gozer
if you're not first you're last am I
right I mean that's very much the
corporate mentality yeah yet at the same
time like they simultaneously go if
you're not first you're last they also
go do what the other people are doing
that's making the money
so simultaneously they want to be the
most successful while also just ripping
off whatever other ideas making money
somewhere else
don't worry Black cover I'm not gonna
spoil spiderverse as I said my review is
out on Thursday in the break room front
section of that is spoiler free and I
tell you before I get into spoilers and
I won't even say what topic I'm gonna
Deep dive into on Saturday although I
think anyone who has seen the movie and
or has been paying attention to the
discourse around spider-verse might
already guess at least generally uh what
it's gonna be about although you may not
realize how far I'm gonna take it so
there's that
let's see
a majority of major subreddits have gone
private to protest changes to the site
oh I didn't even know that I actually
haven't been on Reddit in like a month I
asked permission to still see the
culture read it because I miss it and
they told me too bad I mean that is kind
of the nature of of going dark of a
blackout that's yeah that is kind of how
that has to work like I I I'm not trying
to like be flippant about it I'm not
trying to tell you yeah suck it up but
like that is the nature of the action
they're taking that's that is kind of
what they have to do
um
but yeah now I I get where that would be
frustrating yeah I didn't know that was
going on on Reddit because I have not
been paying attention to Reddit I think
the last subreddit I was on with any
semi-regularity was a um spicy site uh
advice
one you know where people like ask
questions or give their thoughts on you
know better ways to
promote yourself or to structure your
pricing or whatever on that certain
spicy site
I haven't really done much on there
other than that in a bit
damn maybe posted some burlesque stuff
I don't know
uh can't remember now why can't Studios
figure out how to Market pulp movies
because
most Studios don't know
how to not take things super seriously
and I know that sounds weird given like
the complaints about like the Marvel
sense of humor on the and the equip it
equip quip quip stuff that goes on and
you might think well they're not taking
any see anything seriously well no the
characters aren't but the studios are
and the marketing is they take that
quipping very seriously that's why it's
in everything
and generally
pulp you need to treat
as disposable because that's what it's
designed to be me I mean part of the
problem is we don't get that many
genuine pulp movies we get a lot of
things aping a pulp aesthetic and a pulp
sensibility but often if they're being
produced by the major Studios they have
been they have major money behind them
so they only really have the affectation
of Pulp
but in general you know
asking why don't they know uh how to
Market movies that you know are designed
to be Niche and disposable is is you
know kind of like asking why do Major
Video Game Publishers not put out more
you know 2D pixel art farming Sims
that's not what they know how to do it
just isn't
the moment where the valley yard is
checking the exploding quills and the
master just reeks of years of pent-up
anger
uh yeah well we get we'll be getting to
uh yeah so the
second part of trial of the time Lord
that review went up in the break room
earlier today if folks haven't seen it
um
yeah trial of Time Lord is an
interesting thing
uh I do got to tell you though the
valley yard
I don't know about him I have not seen
the teaser trailer Brandon I might take
a look at it after this maybe I'll even
shoot a uh
a reaction video I don't know but uh
I've noted before
Pixar trailers even to Pixar movies I
end up liking usually don't do much for
me and I'll tell you all right can I
just say something about Elemental
The more I've seen those trailers like
in front of YouTube stuff or like
showing up in my Tick Tock feed
the mouths on those characters are
really ugly
like the the shapes
and the way they move in the extremities
of the mouth movements it's really
off-pitting like it's it's really uh
it's like visceral to me it's like oh no
ooh I actually kind of hate it
one of my favorite Mad Magazine jokes
from their honest corporate slogans
Department
Coke see what Pepsi's doing try that
Pepsi see what Coke's doing try that I
love Mad Magazine I have a box of of Mad
magazines from the 90s up in the attic
somewhere how to dig those out sometime
if Doctor Who was played by the mayor by
an American actor who would you like
um I'll just go with the last answer I
gave when I uh sort of responded to the
idea on Twitter uh Janelle Monae
thank you very much
do you feel wary when male creators
write female queer characters because I
feel the intensely the fetishization
just look at some of whedon's work I
mean
I'm wary on whether or not they assumed
they knew what they were doing or did
they consult with somebody because like
here's the thing some people get really
hung up on the idea you know anybody can
write anything yes if they do the
legwork to understand it otherwise
they're writing something based off a
lot of probably bad assumptions so
yeah it's it is a it is an easier trap
to fall into but at the same time like
uh women writers and queer writers are
just as equally capable of fetishizing
their characters that's not a uniquely
um
uh male male writer male Creator problem
but it does feel like it goes unchecked
most there or at least historically it
has it I feel like it's slowly generally
getting better uh Dharma thank you very
much uh member 18 months Dang A Team by
Alice Cooper blasts out the speakers
nice very nice
Michael Jackson almost became the doctor
I've heard that I've never seen that
well substantiated
my suspicion is that his name just got
tossed out randomly at some point
I think Trump might have got a second
term without covid so I think it depends
if you think delaying fascism is worth
millions of deaths I don't know the
answer to that
um
um I don't know well like it's possible
that he might have won but for kovid
I mean it's a it's a what-if game you
can make any number of arguments
it would have been closer
certainly but that's that's also a bit
that's a
a calculation you have proposed a
calculation I do not feel comfortable
even trying to make
spicy side advice about the spicy site
yeah
using all the coded language up in here
I I think I've gone so far as to
actually just say the name of the site
like on the twitch stream
and I'm tuned I'm too squirrely about
how
um YouTube can be here to just flat out
say it people know what I'm talking
about right
uh did you ever see a review of the
eighth doctor movie The Peter Cushing
movies
um I have yes I've seen the X doctor
movie there was a review that it is on
my channel
um that I actually did with Stu bag full
that was a while ago that was some years
back and I did a review of the second of
the Peter Cushing ones last year
um it wasn't my intention to do that one
first first
do that one first
but I did that one first because
um Bernard cribbins uh was in it and he
had passed away so I bumped that one up
and did that one first so I do have a
review of that one up I summoned on the
first one of the Peter crushing movies
uh what is a movie that uses pulp
aesthetic versus an actual pulp movie
okay so like
Quentin Tarantino loves his pulp
aesthetic
but I would consider something like say
Shoot Em Up to be more legitimately Pope
and like I'm I'm I can't quantify that
for you live on stream but that's sort
of like my gut feeling in a lot of ways
aren't you worried your Mad Magazines
will waste away not exceptionally
did I ever watch Mad TV a little in its
first year not a ton
I get why the mods can't make exceptions
but too bad with so laconic and
dismissive it hurt my feelings a little
bit I get that
I I do get that they could have they
could have worded it more politely
certainly
uh
uh where are we at here
I'm re-watching black mirror and season
one has the episode with Jody Whitaker
in it it does that was not too bad
um it's
like there aren't that many there are
really only two
episodes of Black Mirror that I don't
think
fully work
um and then there are a number that
aren't that don't work for me but I
don't think are
full-on failures in any way
um but most of Black Mirror is really
good
only cans
[Laughter]
uh actually I I meant to go to another
site I was trying to look up stuff on
desserts I was looking for only flans
uh
uh zamir Patois thank you for the Super
Chat
I have four big fat birds with fat and
round plump bodies uh my kiddo would
refer to those as borbs
because there's burbs which are little
ones and then there's borbs which are
the big round ones because they are
orb-like so they're borbs
it's not two rabbits in my area the
other day oh cute
sergiore gonace is alive thank heavens
yep yeah he's still kicking ah
his his margin Doodles were one of my
favorite things to find in Madden
magazines he's really good
he's just an absolute Delight his stuff
and guru's a lot of fun too
I think in 50 years there'll be a lot of
alternate history about the pandemic
never happening and Trump becoming
dictator of America plausible or not
plausible that there'll be a lot of
alternate history fiction yes absolutely
is it plausible that it would have
happened
I don't know
just for my own Peace of Mind I'd prefer
not to go down that particular
Rabbit Hole of thought hey Meg good to
see you glad you could make it
uh let's see
but Casta I I take I like
I have checked on the things I have in
the Attic they're not rotting I have not
pulled them out in a long time but like
just a don't do that
huh how do I ask I left a YouTuber an
introspective question without seeming
like I'm trolling I don't know
um if the if the Lefty YouTuber is me
just go ahead and ask it you're a
regular in my chat so I know you're
probably mean it sincerely
um but
the thing is
folks on the left
unless they're real careful can unless
they're carefully taking a look at
things and taking context into account
and at least occasionally giving people
the benefit of the doubt sincere
questions can really easily resemble
troll questions and that's not the part
of the quest the fart
the fault
yes I am 14.
um that's not the fault of the person
asking the question sincerely that's the
fault of all the trolls who have
um done similar things in bad faith but
other than just rolling the dice I
really don't uh
I really don't know
any kind of Secret Sauce to to make that
work shoot him up is such a bizarre one
in my taste that despise guns I dislike
gun porn I load the kind of stuff
conservative gun cultures into but it's
such utter nonsense I love it it is like
Shoot Em Up
practically an alternate reality movie
it's it I I I like that movie a lot it's
a lot of fun I like it for the same
reason I like things like gunpowder
milkshake
I I can it can be iffy for me to get
into you know more hard-hitting thing
and I'm definitely not okay with gun
culture
or a lot of the other stuff but like
things like Desperado or gunpowder
milkshake or Shoot Em Up I really do
love those movies they were they're just
a lot of fun
uh
I love the margin drawings yeah marching
drawings are classic
Barry keeps a clean and dry attic thank
you very much
uh does your upcoming spider-verse video
have anything to do with similar topics
as Ms Earl's recent after dark drop yes
although I have not I have not had the
time to fully listen to that so I don't
know if anyone there goes
um
for the uh
uh goes for the angle I'm gonna take but
it's not what I've seen in general
because a lot of a lot of the focus of
that discussion that uh Missouri Jesse
uh had
who is largely focused around one
character
uh Saturday's video I will be expanding
that conversation to a much broader
analysis and applying that lens to a lot
more than just that one character
that's what I'm saying
it's not you it was someone else I'm not
sure if he was ignoring me or if I was
beneath notice I mean depending on how
busy the chat was he might he also might
not have noticed
I mean that that happens
the Blu-ray of season 23 features an
alternate version of Terror of the verb
boy verb boy
ver B boys
with better CGI and without the trial
segments oh
trial segments for the better part of
that is Carolyn here tonight
um not at the moment I know that that
she was out
um doing some stuff earlier and she had
told me she might not make it back in
time for the stream but I will let her
know that you asked after her Meg I
think she'll like to hear that
the thing about Doctor Who directors
reminded me that Cronenberg was almost
allowed to direct the last original Star
Wars film do you how do you think that
would have turned out I don't know I
also know they asked David Lynch
so I have no idea how that would have
turned out
but I mean I suspect the main reason
neither of them took it up is both of
them want more creative control than
George Lucas would have given them
you know to like actually shape the
story and whatnot
if you ever watch Velma well I'm never
going to unless somebody pays me so yeah
I won't even don't even worry about it
if you could bring one monster and one
character from classic into new who
which would you pick so I'm assuming you
mean ones who have not already been
featured I am going to go with Jamie
McCrimmon and Omega
if we count him as a monster he's I mean
he's a villain he could debate whether
or not he's a monster but that's what
that's what I'm going with
I've actually never heard of shoot him
up in my mind pulp is more fantasy
sci-fi like Sky pirate by the way is
that why the movie's called Pulp Fiction
I never understood that yeah that's
exactly why because the thing is to keep
in mind pulp pulp wasn't really it
wasn't originally a genre there were
certain genres that were pulp genres but
pulp Itself by its initial definitions
just meant
cheap and disposable and just crank it
out nobody cares and it was dominated by
yes cheesy uh fantasy and sci-fi but
also most you know Noir magazines
detective stories Femme Fatale stuff
most queer stories you know in the 40s
and 50s were pulp
so you know it's it kind of extends out
in that way
do
so I I see we've gotten into fried green
tomatoes on the subject of Secret Sauce
hmm
[Music]
I watched a lot of reaction videos on
the side something that keeps coming up
again and again is the super it's stupid
I I cannot talk tonight
uh
the stupid wizard school books I never
hear acknowledgment of the issues
especially with the Twitter at the top
and hear constant gushing I I feel this
bugs me way more than I should
um I don't think it bugs you more than
it should
because this kind of actually comes back
to something that I was talking about
towards the very beginning of the stream
uh which was when I was talking about
how creators can kind of get trapped in
a certain kind of content if that's what
they're known for and that's what's
making them their money either they are
unwilling to try and Branch out and take
the risk or they tried to Branch out and
it wasn't as successful and they go back
to it
um you know and they just they just keep
doing it because of what's it's what
makes the money now I talked about that
originally
in the context of not all conservative
creators honestly believing what they
talk about especially the the really
screamy anti-woke kinds but that I think
honestly applies to a lot of the
creators who still talk about that about
the wizard School franchise
I don't watch their stuff but I it's
been asked of me repeatedly in regards
to say I think it's the supercarlin
brothers who I don't know and I don't
watch their stuff and like back when her
transphobia became undeniable you know
they they kind of put out some like we
don't support this we're not okay with
this but they kept making the content
they kept making stuff about it because
that was a big part of their brand and
like I'm not immune from this
when the BBC put out that
horrendously transphobic article
two years ago now
year and a half something like that
basically the start of why I have the
disclaimer at the front of my Doctor Who
stuff
I part of me wanted to be able to just
say I'm done with Doctor Who
but there was a financial reality to it
I could not I literally could not and
this isn't even like a case of I have
employees to watch out for like no I'm
basically a one-person show
um I I I
um I have a thumbnail guy that's it this
is pretty much a one-person show and
it's my own bills
I if I stop talking about Doctor Who
entirely
that would be a significant hit
to my income and even beyond that I
don't know
if there's if I could come up with
topics to fill the gap for as often as I
talk about it and I don't feel great
about that now I feel better about that
than if I kept talking about the wizard
School uh franchise because the problem
with the BBC is the news arm and the
current creatives heading up Doctor Who
have especially RTD have not only not
expressed those kinds of transphobic
sentiments they've actively called the
mountain spoke out against them so that
helps that the people actually
directingly directingly holy cow
directly making the product aren't
aren't um
aren't the problem you know the way the
single originator of the entire
Wizarding franchise is the problem
but
I do understand how
creators can feel kind of Trapped By the
topic
and I'm not
unsympathetic
but also at a saint at the same time at
a certain point like sympathy dries up
after a while
Rim Omega
comic question I always wonder why the
90s get more disliked than any other
decade there were gems in that era not
uh everything was life-filled in the
clone saga
it wasn't
but a disproportionate amount of it was
like you say life life held in the clone
saga as if those were the only other if
as if those were the only two things
like that
um the the in the majority of image and
their output DC introduced Justice
League extreme
like the 9 90s Comics was an infection
and a virus and most of the industry was
afflicted with it
was it the entirety of the decade was it
everything that was put out no but it
was most of it
and I think the big thing is that it
it infected and swallowed up
characters and properties and and
universes that
it really didn't suit like
love them or hate him
most of what liefeld did
was to his own original Creations like
cable was absurd but he created cable
he created the original X-Force most of
those characters
and there's a reason why the biggest
meme image from lifelt is that drawing
of Captain America with the chest that's
out further than my tits are
so the reason why that is because
Captain America specifically is not
supposed to look like that but a lot of
characters who should not have been
drawn or written that way were you
should see some of the stuff they were
doing to the Fantastic Four in the 90s
I've got an issue with Fantastic Four
unlimited it is painful
it's it's drawn by herb trimpy who's an
artist I don't like in general but boy
you could feel his pain in every line
that basically somebody in editorial
told him draw more like liefeld and you
could feel his artistic Soul dying
hola
anyone see the second Shazam I finally
got around to it took me a few settings
to finish it that one's real low on my
list at this point
um Zachary Levi uh outing himself as uh
as a real turd that's kind of put a
damper on what little interest I had
so
if beyond the spider verse doesn't bring
in Christopher Daniel Barnes and Neil
Patrick Harris I'm going to be very
upset well just cross your fingers
uh
uh I was skeptical of RTD taking over
initially now I'm like go Russell go I
like I hope it works I really do
no no I don't mean people who focus on
the Wizarding franchise I meant people
who react to movies in general in that
Series in particular just keeps coming
up oh oh
okay I gotcha yeah like it can still
hurt I get that
255 A.D BBC is a media institution not
one awful person yeah it's a it's a it's
a system and it's it's more complicated
to
dissect and hold accountable
do you have to be extreme to be a man's
man no on a uh an extreme person is
different from a man's man because you
can do a man's man and be the Suave
thing and Suave is not the same as
extreme
so it's kind of a it's kind of a
different vibe
personality I love your cake on geekdom
but I don't like Doctor Who I leave vids
open in the browser review so you get
the ad Revenue engagement from the
algorithm oh
thank you I appreciate that
it's very thoughtful uh I'm gonna have
to check the Discord I'll be late to
that actually because Carolyn wasn't
here to remind me
um
uh but let me just see real quick oh
yeah and there and there's the reminders
there's the reminders about
the Discord anyway if someone wants to
fill in Ms Wicked Wolf about Zachary
Levi uh or also Kate cast reviews like
just
the the standard right
religiously oriented nonsense it's just
all popping up
yeah okay you know what actually give me
a hot second I'll
I'll do some quick
checking on that for you folks
Zachary Levi
and also annoyingly uh that's a
performance name
uh and he's not like a lot of people
assume he's Jewish because of the last
name he's not that's a stage that's a
that's a screen name or actually I think
it's a middle name
it's not his actual last name anyways
where was it
he's been on Twitter like his uh
somebody needs to take
Twitter away from him like so many
um
celebrities
let's see
oh yeah he followed he started following
um gays against groomers which if you
don't know is just an anti-trans hate
group
[Music]
um
so yeah so he started following them
that's the most recent one
um
what was the other one
there was something prior to that
this is the most recent stuff
oh yeah he went anti-vaxx earlier in the
year
um
yeah so earlier this year he basically
came out as anti-vaxx
um
and yeah and like I said he started
following uh a blatantly anti-trans uh
Twitter
account
yeah and he's he's had some he's had
some homophobic stuff in the past I
don't have the specifics on that but
yeah it's a fair bit of stuff anyways I
gotta pop over the Discord answer those
questions reminder the page the uh
castle of geese Discord is a patreon
exclusive perk so if you support me if
we're on patreon at two dollars or more
a month you get access to the Discord
and now I'm gonna check out the
questions from there let's see if I can
get through these in a reasonable amount
of time maybe do you have any tips for
not burning out on content making such
as writing
um
I mean the main thing with content
Creation in general that I always say is
Don't Force It I mean try and work on it
on a regular basis but if you force it
into the shape of work then it will feel
more like work do it because you want to
do it not because you feel obligated to
do it that's my main tip but also keep
in mind that you know writing is going
to be a little bit different than say
video creation part of the reason that I
haven't gotten more writing done is that
it's it's hard for me to finish
long-term stuff and so I don't have the
best advice in the world
um for how to how to go about that
have you been a GM for a tabletop RPG I
have not and I would be terrible I think
I would make a very good like co-gm like
um doing like doing NPCs
um or stuff like that but like the
amount of planning that they have to be
prepared to do no no I'd be terrible I
don't know if you've already been asked
but what is your view on using Mary Sue
as an insult for someone's original
character is it ever warranted so in the
strictest sense for what a Mary's who
actually is which is not just like well
it's not just any female character first
of all nor is it just any character who
seems a little bit over qualified or
over skilled specifically a Mary Sue is
meant to denote a self-insert character
around whom other characters act out of
character
um simply to make the Mary Sue seem more
important
so that's the nature of a Mary Sue is it
ever warranted yeah rarely because a
legitimate Mary Sue is very very rare
especially at this point and honestly
especially at a fan fiction circles it's
a fan fiction Trope that's where the
phrase originates from in terms of even
if you're using it accurately I feel
like it's become such a loaded term that
it's not worth using just overall
because it just starts an argument over
the definition but like yeah sometimes
it can be warranted but even in those
cases it's probably better just to
criticize it for the things that a Mary
Sue is rather than slap the label on it
because the label is going to derail the
conversation
ah
in your video you said we shouldn't
criticize a seemingly CIS head actor for
taking a queer role unless they made
public statements clearly indicating
that they are CIS and hat what if it's a
situation where an actor hasn't
explicitly said what their sexuality or
gender is but they've taken a lot of
public stances that would seem to
indicate they're either not queer or
must be like self-loathing or something
if they are like so far as I'm aware
Chris Pratt has never said he's entirely
hetero but he was a conservative and
went to an lgbtq church he he didn't I
did a video on that but anyways
you're you're getting more granular than
I am prepared to do especially with
hypotheticals
like as I would say nothing is ever
always and these things take nuance and
kind of have to be dealt with on a
case-by-case basis which people don't
want to do because it's more work people
want sweeping rules that they can just
stamp and apply to everything which does
not work that's how we get the kit
Connor situation but
um
like
strictly speaking most people don't have
to say they're straight they are
presumed straight
and so it does it can in theory get
messed if someone is simply not
indicating and have not strictly said
what they are but
we're also at a time where
if someone has made any sense of their
sexuality publicly known we kind of have
to go off the information we have
because so this is a weird comparison
kind of like how
when I see a trailer and I think it
looks bad and people say well you can't
judge it it's not the whole movie it's
like no but I can judge what you've
shown me
I don't like to go in assuming the
marketing department is lying to me I
don't like to go into a situation and
assuming that a celebrity or someone
else is deliberately lying or
deliberately withholding information
unless they I have made it very clear I
just don't want to answer those
questions which is what you get in cases
like shittigatwa
so I don't like and I don't find it
useful to Tumble down the what if
scenario
uh pit trap that is what if what if what
if this what if this what if what if we
don't know isn't it possible yes it's
possible
but deal with it on our case-by-case
basis work off the information you have
How likely is it
that's kind of where I'm at
a while back I found a video of Ian
Banks on YouTube from the early 2000s
where he's showing a camera crew around
his house and talking about his writing
routine but then uh by then the culture
series was very popular so the video of
all banks showing off stuff like his car
collection and for the time state of the
art Mac he'd bought with the money he'd
made from his books I don't want to say
socialism is what is when no house or
whatever but do you think it's kind of
icky to write a book series about how
wealth is evil and ideal future would
like money and then display the level of
conspicuous consumption in your own life
I mean there's a level of dissonance
there but it's also
just very human
you know
my gut instinct on that is that unless
unless he was running like
unless he had a significant pull in like
the banking industry you know the actual
heart of the capitalist Society
I I see it as fairly harmless hypocrisy
as long as he's not screwing anybody
over to make more money if this is just
how he's choosing to spend the money
that he made from his creation that yes
uh
sort of didn't endorse capitalism or
wealth or any of that then like
dude I kind of wish you'd thought of
something else to spend your money on
but if that's what you're going to spend
your money on fine
you're not hurting anybody
uh you ever read a scientific science
fiction about a fictional society that
is some really good idea uh some really
good and really bad elements you can't
tell which part the author is and isn't
endorsing
remember I told you about the book set
in the Neanderthal Society where people
are observed all the time to other
aspects of their society are people uh
is everyone has both a male partner and
a female partner and they punish
criminals by castrating them and their
children I came away thinking so does
this author think both queer polyamory
and Eugenics are good or just the former
or neither
um and that's again that's going to be a
massive case-by-case thing because
it's fully possible that the uh that the
reader is not intended to fully Embrace
or fully reject this Society but is
meant to view it as any society would be
as flawed some stuff that's good ideas
some stuff that's really bad ideas that
would be my gut instinct again I haven't
read it I don't know
do you find it as frustrating as I do
when show a characters compassion for
others as a weakness for instance when
Dustin took in baby demig organs as pets
in stranger things three it really
irritated me that instead of showing his
well it was stranger things too
I know that because I kind of like
season three in season two I don't like
at all
um very much other than Steve other than
Stephen Dustin together
um I really don't like season season two
it really irritated me that instead of
showing his compassionate side as a
positive trait the show made it out as
though he was stupid for Carrie and for
some reason this kind of thing happens
all the time uh whenever you see someone
try to befriend or calm down on unknown
alien or creature so
it is a very easy trap where
writers will treat compassion as if it
was synonymous with naivety or naivete
or however you want to pronounce that
and it's not if you want some good
recent examples that dispute that I
would say both the owl house and also
kippo and the age of Wonder beasts you
have in both of those very
very compassionate
uh lead characters
who are also not naive and they
recognize when compassion is not going
to help they recognize when they're
dealing with a force or an individual
for whom expressing their usual degree
of compassion and benefit of the doubt
would be foolish
the the Trap that I think a lot of
writers fall into is this idea that
compassion is an All or Nothing thing
you either show it to everyone in which
case you do something stupid or you show
it to nobody in which case you're a
cold-hearted badass which is usually
presented as being a better thing than
it should be but yeah that that is that
is a problem
how often that happens
uh do you ever think it's okay for
certain characters to be autism coded uh
if it's never brought up in the show I'm
conflicted because to my favorite autism
coded characters are data and 11. so for
the purposes of autistic representation
it would be nice to say definitively if
they if they are autistic however I'm
not sure if there's a way you can do
that in their shows that would make
sense narratively well daily you
definitely can't because
you know he's not
he's not human so like trying to
diagnose an Android with a
human brain neurodiverging condition
just gets weird just conceptually it
gets weird I suppose there are ways you
can try and make it work but
so
here's the thing
I have in the past railed against the
coding of characters instead of just
coming out and saying it
I don't want people to mistake that for
me thinking that coding is never valid
because it can be the thing to remember
about coding is it helps if you can be
aware of it to the best of your ability
so you don't accidentally code something
horribly
and accidentally do coding that's like
oh no no no no no no
good go-to example being the Goblins in
the uh in The Wizarding franchise like
the coding on that intended or not is a
real bad
but the thing is where I tend to get
really annoyed is when either creators
or more often the marketing wings of
corporate entities
try and push coding as if it counted as
representation
like
it really it bothered me as much as I
like the first season of Loki it
bothered me with Sylvie that they
wouldn't just come out and say she's
trans because she's heavily coded as
trans to the point that I think it would
have actually helped the story to just
say that
but they didn't
and there was you know this talk of oh
we've got this this representation in
here and they there there's
documentation that Loki's gender fluid
I'm like it's literally just on a piece
of paper oh and Loki is by yes and you
have a trans-coded character sitting
right there and if you actually intend
them to represent transness and trans
people then say it if you don't intend
them to actually represent that and you
have just ended up with a character who
codes and fits into that template but
you're doing something else with them
fine but don't take credit for that
got a little worked up there
why do you think uh companies so rarely
operate on a principle of innocent until
proven guilty when it comes to dealing
with criminal investigations involving
actors a PR
like like that's it uh it comes across
as whatever an allegation is made
against an accurate companies will try
everything they can to get rid of them
even if they've yet to be proven to have
done anything wrong yeah it's PR it's
just PR
it has nothing I I have said this so
many times it has nothing to do with an
actual moral judgment by the companies
involved they don't actually pass moral
judgment they don't have a moral compass
they're companies they don't actually
even really care if the actor in
question did or didn't do the thing
what they care about is the public
perception and how that affects their
bottom line and if the public perception
is currently very bad because like the
thing to remember
innocent until proven guilty is the
responsibility of the legal system of
the court system it does not apply in
the court of public opinion now you can
feel that that is wrong but it is still
the reality people will form their
opinions regardless most people even if
they say they don't do this but most
people will form an opinion around what
someone is accused of doing long before
a trial that is even held much less a
verdict reached because the court of the
court of public opinion is not beholden
to the restrictions limitations and
guidelines of the actual court system
and because the court of public opinion
is ultimately what uh these companies
care about they care about the
perception they care about the pr they
care about whether or not the visibility
of an embattled actor is going to
negatively impact their bottom line if
they feel it is they will get rid of
them if they can
that's all it is it's not about
disregarding innocent until proven
guilty it's about their bottom line it's
about money
companies exist to make money and
everything they do is designed to either
make them more money or to protect the
money they already have and their
Investments
everything they do
is tied to this
especially as corporations scale up
anything that is more than a mom-and-pop
short mom and pop store down on the
corner
the only reason they do what they do is
for money either because of the direct
Financial benefits or because of the
presumed uh Goodwill that they can then
cash in later whatever it is money is at
the heart of it it's not morals they
don't have them I'm not saying the
individual people running companies
don't have morals though I would
actually argue a lot of them don't but
companies and corporations are
self-preserving entities that run on
money and they have no moral compass
so
there we go
okay
so I'm back
let's see if I can catch up on some
things and then we'll wrap up
going back for some
Super Chat
all right Supremo Mega for the past
decade
are you tired of DC adapting Barry Allen
and Flashpoint so many adaptations why
not Wally West and other Flash comic
story lines
because Dan de Dio and Jeff Johns both
like Barry Allen because they grew up
with him and they threw out the baby
with the bath water and we have been
dealing with the repercussions with that
ever since
like is there a good reason why no but
that's the reason
am I like the thing is I never really
got into DC largely just because I don't
connect with most of those characters
and I really don't connect with the
moves of the company as a whole
I think if DC had respected its Legacy
nature of how many characters had
retired and been replaced with a younger
um generation
I think that was something that really
made them unique and I think I could
have really gotten into that as I you
know became a more mature reader
but then you know
they started just getting rid of the
Legacy characters and bringing back the
iconic characters then they did New 52
and that was basically the entire
impetus for the whole damn thing and
like now I really don't care what DC
does let's not say I don't like any DC
characters but by and large I'm not a DC
fan never really have been
uh one common question do you feel Stan
Lee gets too much credit yeah
uh he gets too much credit as a Creator
what Stanley was Stan Lee was an amazing
pitch man he was a decent ideas guy an
amazing pitch man a fantastic public
face
he was a great personality
he was an okay writer
yeah
but like that's kind of the nature of
the comics industry is you know whoever
created the character gets to put their
name on that forever
and seeing that goes oh you created all
this yeah created may may simply amount
to came up with the concept and handed
it off to an artist who did most of the
writing and they never touch it again
but he still gets Creator credit so yeah
Stan Lee does get too much credit but
that is not to say that Stan Lee
deserves no credit he he was very good
at a lot of what he did
but part of what he did was build up his
own myth
and I think he'd even admit to that like
I will continue to argue that the best
Stanley Cameo ever is in the first
spider-verse movie and that is the
perfect distillation of Stan Lee
the this very sincere presentation that
is ultimately somebody who you probably
shouldn't Trust
and I think to a certain degree he even
understood that about himself
let me see here
you used to do house sorting videos for
other uh characters since that went down
you ever consider doing something like
which characters from
X Mythos would make a best make a doctor
who companion I haven't really because
that kind of requires a more creative
thought about how that would happen and
then I'd have to think about a dynamic
it's it's not a terrible idea but
honestly it's just more work and I don't
know if it would take off or not like
the
sorting people into the Wizarding books
houses is is a really easy pitch
um and it's not that hard to do
ah let's see
all right we've got a couple more
I know I think I've got one more Super
Chat
255 A.D there's a Stargate sg1 where
Daniel's compassion it leads to an alien
taking over the base I like that he
insists wasn't wrong for being
compassionate initially
well that's that's good at least
speaking of PR Ezra seems to have
cleaned up their act well they're
certainly behaving
at present
um
but we'll see I'm I still have no plan
to see the flash because regardless of
whether or not they are getting better
I'm not comfortable watching Miller
right now
and that's that's what I tend to chalk
up to just the factor where like
I've still got it lingering a little bit
for Rosario Dawson and I'm I'm getting
over it I'll get there eventually but
like
where
I should be able to move on like when I
think about it but like there's just a
gut level
um and that's where I'm at with Miller
right now
and I'm also like also kind of paranoid
because we're we're at a point where
they're
being well behaved and being better is
still running for less time than their
Rampage lasted so when they have been
cleaned up for longer than they were a
walking disaster then maybe I'll start
to consider
um
you know them in a better light that's
kind of where I'm at right now
live streams are really great background
noise while I crochet
um thank you I'm glad you enjoyed it did
I ever read Garfield comics yeah back in
grade school
at least Wally is the main flash once
again I think I I don't know I don't
keep track
whatever you do today don't read the
comics broke me hell thread thank you
for the warning I will avoid that
uh yes gate of theories I answered that
question earlier the uh crosses spider
verse review will be up in the break
room on Thursday and on Saturday will be
a more in-depth look at a specific
aspect and reading of that movie except
I'm going to expand it out to bigger
than most people have done it
all right I just had to check I wasn't
misremembering and confusing Cronenberg
and Lynch but apparently both were
approached uh why would lucasfilm think
either would have accepted the
constricts I don't know
I don't know I can't answer that
I'm doing a watch through of the
Jurassic films because 30 years and all
that oh God make me feel old
ow
dude ow
lost world seems really weak Goldblum
really not into it yeah that was I I
kind of enjoyed
um a lot of The Supporting Cast in that
one
how do you reconcile growing older than
a character you've crushed on well uh
thankfully I never really had too many
issues with crushing on like teen
characters so I it's not like I still do
and honestly I just kind of grew out of
it because like when I was a kid I
crushed on Ariel but then I got older
and realized I was queer and now I just
relate to her as a trans allegory and I
don't I don't really crush on her
anymore so I don't
I don't really have an answer to that
it's something that I feel like I
haven't had to reconcile for the most
part
I'll see Jennifer Jaws doesn't make me
feel old because Jaws just gets lumped
under the category of before I was born
that that basically might all just be
one age
ah
ah all right we're gonna wrap it up
welcome
to Jurassic Park
ah
clever girl
geez I say it like that it that that
that sounds like a whole other thing
um uh anyways
closer
that that feels like a last minute below
the Bell blow that one
you just had to sneak that that tidbit
in thanks anyways we're gonna wrap it up
there uh thank you everybody for joining
me I hope everybody uh is doing well I
hope you are having a good pride month
um I will be on Twitch tomorrow at
um
10 30 Eastern uh day like time and I
will probably be playing more Dark Side
Detective and then Thursday will be the
review for spider-verse and Saturday
will be a video on spider-verse uh that
isn't a review and that will be here on
this channel that's what's coming up and
I hope you all uh be well
be safe be kind and remember that you
are beautiful you are valid
and you are loved
mccavity hey